I just saw on the calendar that right now on Earth
it's almost Christmas time we don't
have time for trivialities like Christmas
but Peter's so sad about Gamora being gone
we go to Earth they're a really
wonderful Christmas gift happy
something special he will never
forget what about someone special
we are looking for the legendary Kevin Bacon
we're looking for the legendary Kevin Bacon
monster I think maybe you didn't hear
you you're coming with us as a Christmas present
I'm through
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie big surprise
Marvel dropped the trailer for The Guardians of
the Galaxy holiday special there's a whole bunch
of Easter eggs and connections to what's happening
in Marvel phase 4 in Marvel Phase 5 because
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 is a Marvel Phase 5
movie so we'll break it all down I'll explain
where this fits in the canon in the timeline
because it's sort of like in between Marvel phase
4 and Marvel Phase 5 at the end of this year in
a couple weeks we won't have to wait that long to
actually get it if you're brand new to the channel
of course I'll be doing all kinds of videos for
this in the other Marvel special presentations
that they release along with the Disney plus
series and the movies be sure to subscribe to
get everything the whole idea with the Guardians
of the Galaxy holiday special is that as the
name implies it's based on the Star Wars holiday
special very Infamous it's a big rite of passage
as a Star Wars fan to watch the holiday special
if you can make it through the entire thing
you're a champ that's also why the Marvel special
presentation intro scene is meant to look exactly
like the CBS special presentation intro scene like
the logos are almost exactly the same so it's them
doing that but with the Guardians of the Galaxy
MCU characters in the MCU Universe it's meant to
take place right after the events of Thor love and
thunder after the Guardians of the Galaxy takeoff
and Thor goes off on his own his Adventure but
before the events of Guardians of the Galaxy 3.
now I've already done a Guardians of the Galaxy
3 trailer video I'll link that in the description
below and at the end of this because we see Adam
Warlock for the first time we also find out what
happened to Gamora which they're talking about
during this holiday special trailer like part
of the plot is inspired by Peter Quill being so
depressed in the Guardians wanting to cheer him
up and because it's near Christmas and throw a big
Christmas party for a big Christmas celebration
I'm assuming it's about as long in length as
the werewolf By Night Special presentation
also for reference because werewolf by night was
so successful for Marvel because people loved it
so much they do have a lot of plans to do more of
those types of special presentations like one-offs
instead of doing the full Disney plus series or a
full movie for every single character really good
example and cool connection to the Guardians of
the Galaxy is Silver Surfer they've talked about
doing Silver Surfer as a special presentation a
couple months before the new Fantastic Four movie
comes out in a couple years obviously the real big
things that we see during this trailer at least
there are probably a couple big surprises too but
we see the full size version of Groot Alpha Groot
I'll talk about him in a second but also real
life Kevin Bacon like they're canonizing Kevin
Bacon to the MCU now real life Kevin Bacon he's
not playing the Sebastian Shaw X-Men first Class
version of his character but this does canonize
the X-Men films to the MCU because remember real
life Kevin Bacon is an actor he would have
played that role in the X-Men film so while
the movies that that actor made are now Canon
to the MCU this is mostly about the Footloose
reference from Avengers Infinity War so I'm about
to dance off to save the universe what dance off
it's not it's not a it's not I can boost a move
exactly like Footloose is it still the greatest
movie in history it never was don't encourage
this all right you're the real big character
that we see during this although we've seen them
before is Cosmo the space dog but we're actually
gonna see them talk during this movie I think the
idea is that Cosmo also shows up during Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 but this will be the first time
that we've heard her talk so she's a talking dog
voiced by Maria bakalova you've probably seen
her in a couple other things recently in the
MCU in the Marvel Comics her backstory is that
she's a Russian space dog and she's based on a
real-life Russian space dog Laika who the Russians
fired into space on a test flight in the 1950s in
the MCU when she was sent to space she was just
mutated by cosmic rays and wound up on nowhere and
then part of the collector's collection because
this whole thing is that he collects all the
unique things and really valuable things that he
can find that's why he wanted to collect Groot as
well like anything unique that he could find like
oh you need to be part of my collection obviously
she escaped when the collector was killed by
Thanos the other real big surprise is that in the
one sheet that Marvel released for this with like
the entire cast Michael Rooker was also listed in
the cast but they didn't say if he'd be coming
back is a version of yondu either as a flashback
or in some crazy twist in present day or if he be
in it as actual Michael Rooker in a Kevin Bacon
kind of twist like real life Kevin Bacon maybe
it's real life Michael Rooker but I think it's
probably more of a yondu Twist I do not think that
Chris Hemsworth is going to have a cameo is Thor
like they'll probably reference a little bit about
what happened during Thor love and thunder just to
reference the timeline a little bit but obviously
this is meant to take place around the end of
November early December near Christmas time during
this year in the MCU and I believe it's meant to
be the year 2024 because that's around the time
where Thor love and thunder happens so this would
just be like a little bit later that year this is
happening it is supposed to take place after the
events of black panther wakanda forever black
panther wakanda forever is like the last major
Marvel phase 4 movie but this is sort of like a
hanging thread on the end of Marvel phase four
before the official beginning of Marvel Phase
5 the official beginning of Marvel Phase 5 is
Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania I literally
just did a trailer video for that so I'll link
it at the end of this and down in the description
below too because it looks amazing cannot wait to
see King destroy Ant-Man R.I.P Ant-Man so just
starting at the beginning of the trailer footage
though they have the same type of intro that
they had at the beginning of werewolf by night
obviously the difference is they're not doing it
black and white like it looks more like an actual
Marvel Studios Production a movie like you would
expect in full color they play the Christmas music
through the entire trailer just to highlight the
actual season like this is the Christmas season
basically they call it the Holiday trailers
because of all the different religions have
different holidays the planet that they start on
though I believe is meant to be contraxia which
is sort of like the ravager's pleasure planet that
they go to between their missions they just hang
out on all the time craglin becomes a much bigger
character in this and during Guardians of the
Galaxy 3 you also notice he's wearing yandu's Finn
the full fin which he got at the end the Guardians
of the Galaxy 2 he was wearing it during Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 as well oh hey guys you've been
here this whole time yeah you said to stay with
the ship this is Glenda we're married he still
slowly figuring out how to use it the way that
yondu did I think the reason why their costumes
look a little bit more like Guardians of the
Galaxy 2 in this it's just because of the timing
of when they filmed it even though it's meant to
take place after Thor 11 Thunder one of the other
big differences between this in Thor love and
thunder the other Guardians of the Galaxy movies
is that a lot of it seems like it's practical
effects instead of just full special effects
particularly the Alpha version of group like
the full size version of Groot he's not full CG
the comedy here coming from the fact that all the
Guardians are mostly from alien planets they don't
know a lot about Earth culture so they're trying
to figure it out and try to cheer Peter Quill up
they also had a joke about that when craglin gave
Peter Quill the zoomed at the end of Guardians of
the Galaxy 2. now was the present meant to be from
yondu but the whole idea is that they thought that
it was a really big deal like yondu thought that
it was this really huge deal that could hold all
these songs and Cracklin also thought that it was
a really amazing thing but in real life zoons are
this long dead technology basically some of the
Christmas scenes some of the decorations here
are meant to take place on the contraxia planet
and some of it is meant to take place on actual
Earth on actual Hollywood Boulevard because they
do actually travel to earth like what is going on
here this is so weird and it seems like what's
going on here here is that it's just mantis and
Drax that go back to planet Earth on a completely
different ship like this isn't the banatar it's
completely different ship they go back to Earth
to steal Kevin Bacon and bring him back to try
and cheer Peter Quill up but they're basically
kidnapping him like that's the whole comedy like
are you the real life Kevin Bacon you need to come
with us right now and if it wasn't clear if you've
never been to Hollywood Boulevard in Los Angeles
California this is the real Hollywood Boulevard
like James Gunn literally just filmed them walking
around with everybody else in the broad daylight
this is very near man's Chinese Theater and the
theater across the street that Disney actually
owns where they hold a lot of their premieres
so on this street here like right next to this
block is where Marvel has a lot of their movie
premieres this is still contraxia they just all
dressed it up like Christmas this seems like Drax
and mantis having fun while they're on planet
Earth like they're partying it up with a bunch
of regular people there's also a yarvo Easter egg
in the background too during these scenes yarvo
is actually the name of a director in real life
who's just really good friends with James Gunn
who he also produces movies for I believe he's
also the person that directed breitburn unit has
been they're celebrating Christmas on contraxia
they're all wearing the Christmas sweaters Drax
is wearing the meme sweater of the cat with the
laser eyes we see the full-size version of Groot
so presumably he's grown to full size at some
point maybe at the beginning of this maybe
they'll have some joke about that during the
actual holiday special and they have the big joke
about them going to steal Kevin Bacon against his
will it seems like we don't see any scenes of him
on actual contraxia but they might actually pay
that off during the course of the special like
they actually do wind up stealing him and take
him to contraxia it'll be interesting to see what
kind of dance-off joke they pay off when he shows
up because that was the whole thing with Peter
Quill you mean like Footloose oh exactly like
Footloose referencing the dance off at the end of
the first Guardians of the Galaxy movie because
that's what happened at the end of the Footloose
movie the whole joke was is they had a big dance
off at the end of Footloose so maybe maybe small
chance of Kevin Bacon and Peter Quill dancing at
the end of this somehow as far as I know though
Gamora is not going to be in this they'll probably
just reference her but we do actually know what
happened to Gamora because I did a whole video
on the Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer they
released she is now the de facto leader of the
ravagers like she's filled the power vacuum and I
believe it's meant to be a big surprise for Peter
quilt and the other Guardians at the beginning of
the Guardians of Galaxy 3. like at the beginning
of the movie they go to Doc with a dark Easter
that the ravagers are still using the piece of
it that survived part of it was blown up but not
all the ship and when the door opens they pull
all their guns on them and the big reveal is that
the leader that they're there to meet is Gamora
like she walks through and they're all surprised
like Peter Quill can't believe it so it's like
Gamora has gone full Thanos sort of taking over
her own small slice of territory but it's the
ravagers this time and she's acting more like a
space pirate like you would expect the ravagers
too so one of the ongoing plot lines is them
sort of winning Gamora back to the family so to
speak the Guardians of the Galaxy because she's a
completely different version of the character who
had none of those experiences with them from the
first film the other big story line next to Adam
Warlock obviously is the high evolutionary and I
believe he's meant to be the person who created
a rocket I talk about that during my Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 trailer so you can watch that if you
want to learn more about him but the big news here
like I said is that the holiday special is coming
out nov November 25th we just got that Ant-Man
3 trailer so there'll probably be a couple other
trailers before the end of the year as well too
if you have any big questions about what's going
on during this or how it fits into the Canon or
what's going on with the characters when this
picks up just write them in the comments below
but we'll get more trailers for this as we get
a little bit closer so I'll do more bonus videos
and obviously I'll do like a full breakdown in
easter eggs just like I did for werewolf by night
also links for my werewolf by night video down in
the description below too everyone click here
for that full Guardians of the Galaxy 3 trailer
video and click here for my full Ant-Man and
the wasp quantumania trailer video in Easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!